this team is putting together what they
believe to be the first magazine ever
fully produced using artificial
intelligence or AI image
I wanted to publish this artificial
intelligence produced magazine for the
first time in Iran or maybe the world to
tell my audiences and entrepreneurs that
a great development is being made in the
world and we should understand it as
soon as possible otherwise we will be
Looking Backward in the past few years
artificial intelligence has emerged as
the world's most advanced technological
development it refers to a computer or
machine's ability to perform tasks that
typically require human intelligence
including writing and researching
producing a magazine using AI will still
require Akbar to choose his stories and
then his team of technicians generate
the content through a different AI
software
this picture that you see now has been
created by mid-journey we fit it with
what we want and this is the outcome and
now it's going to be used on the front
page of the magazine later we'll get our
chat GPT produced content and add to the
issue then it's ready to be printed the
final product looks just like any other
magazine except its content was
introduced by humans there are some
concerns about the potential lockdown
impact on jobs but many believe just
like other technological achievements of
the past centuries it will enhance the
quality of products and create more
opportunities the AI Buzz here isn't
limited to journalism Iran is aiming to
become one of the world's top 10
countries for AI technology in the
coming 10 years
here at one of tehran's biggest digital
Parks several AI powered projects are in
the making
startups are investing more in AI
facilities and Equipment because they
believe it's going to be essential for
the country's economy the use of AI in
Iran has extended to its Armed Forces as
well recently the Revolutionary Gods
Naval Commander announced his forces are
acquiring ai-powered equipment that are
capable of warning each other if any
vessel comes under attack a move that
reflects Iran's growing Reliance on
artificial intelligence and the impact
it could have on its future as it
struggles onto sanctions Tehran